gen Z slang so
I thought it'd be fun to I I did we were
talking about with the producers
um if we could try to guess what certain
slang words mean because it's always fun
to play a little game yeah and I do feel
ancient
uh and not to cap or anything but
I don't I don't know what a lot of [__]
looks oh God you sound old yeah Chad GPT
what do we think that is I have no idea
a really smart bro maybe no uh is it
when like chat GPT like
just
takes your [__] I don't know
Chad GPT is the chat who's always using
chat GPT to think for him and always
swears it was his idea ah nice example
there Cody has become such a Chad GPT
you know he has no original thoughts
these days sweet come on man Jesus
Christ some dogs I'm never gonna live
that down I'm gonna say sweet feet is a
term of endearment for someone who likes
yeah nice nice feet hey there sweet feet
a hot chick with pretty feet that I love
with all my heart oh God example my
pretty wife Noel has the sweetest feet
on the planet hey sweet feet Noel can
you grab me a beer my love please and
thank you nice
yeah that one X the uh former former
former ex-wife beautiful feet I didn't
even care about feet until uh and then
she was like look how cute my feet are
and I was like God damn they are really
just started sucking on them started I
gave him a little rub
it's a very nice feat sweet sweet feet
if I do say so myself
yeah dude pick me uh this is when like a
a person it's typically used for women
but it's just a person who uh kind of
says what uh someone like
it says what someone wants to hear to be
like you know the pick me of the group
got it yeah like a dude walks in a room
is like [__] oh Bush lights actually
good and she's like yeah I agree and
then all the girls are like you're a
pick me yeah it's like it sounds
adjacent to a stand yeah a stand no Stan
is mad different though well a stand is
a is a die-hard fan but a pick me is
adjacent in the sense that they aim to
please sure kind of yeah yeah it's a
person who aims to play but I think
Stan's aim to like uh get a piece of
hair
right
right did you watch swarm not yet I
started tell me don't tell me don't tell
me [__] insane you started beef yeah
I'm five episodes on beef damn five yeah
that show was depressing me on episode
two I was like all right this is like
too [__] dark or something I need a
break what yeah you never had road rage
and want to just [__] chase down
someone for the rest of their life uh no
I let it you're not the Russell Crowe I
thought you were I let it go man
definition the type of person who
constantly begs for attention and
approval and has to make everything
about themselves yeah hmm
Ben has such a pick me has such pikmi
behavior when he smokes cigs for
attention I'm not smoking cigarettes for
attention I'm smoking cigarettes because
they're good not anymore though no not
anymore but I mean yeah they're not good
they're totally not flop corns this like
dry [__] on the edge of your penis Jesus
Christ
uh I'm gonna disagree with that I'm
gonna say flop corn is a word to
describe when someone [__] up like oh
damn he flopped he on flat Corner wait
wait no I got some milk this popcorn is
that like crust on like a uh like a frat
guy sandal
oh sorry man I know that's less gross
it's just yeah crust foot crust what is
it
the kernels and
what man oh my God that is so lame this
corn flies oh my god dude and the
example man somebody riding these really
has it out for me example when I got to
the bottom of the popcorn bag there were
quite a few flop corns there and it
reminded me of Ben for some reason dude
Ben's already going through it you ain't
got to call him flop corn no you can do
that dude popcorn
did a [__] did a oh man did a
buzzfeed writer come up with this this
is horrible dude flop corn J name Theory
that's the theory that any name starting
with J is a [__] boy or a or a uh pick
me oh you probably got me there dude
wait wait hold on I'm not gonna read it
J name theory is this something Kanye
came up with all right
sorry I'm not sorry go ahead what is it
theory that any guy whose name starts
with a J is complete crap hey nice work
brother very few guys for example hey do
you remember my ex J Ben
that's very funny damn your XXX wife
wrote this that's very funny
oh I dated J Ben back in the day
yo that should be your new name
I mean my middle name the glasses are
off your day then Jewish men yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
no that's not a Ben that's J Ben that's
J Ben that's my Jewish band that's my uh
Evil Nemesis or Alter Ego once Urkel
becomes Stefan
but the opposite yeah J Ben what is a
Coke hold is that when you [__] just
love cocaine and it's ruining your life
it either has to do with this is a trick
because it's either got to do with
cocaine or it's like Diet Coke and I bet
the example is Gonna Knock me in some
way yeah boy Ben's got a real coke hold
on his uh
it's when you're addicted to diet coke
okay oh Coco I thought this is when you
watch your girlfriend get [__] [__] oh
cuckold
a conversation with a person who has
done a lot of coke that you can't get
away from oh I see oh no they turned
this one on Cody after doing his third
rail in 10 minutes Cody turn to me and
just started rambling about life's
deeper meanings I wanted to get away but
I couldn't I was caught in a Coke hold
oh that's when someone's jacked uh but
you can't tell because they're wearing
clothes yeah or like uh yeah
I was just
I actually think it's just that example
is just going to be Ben a picture of it
yeah what's the let's see come on a
physique that is not appealing to the
naked eye yup that's you yep definitely
you oh
[Music]
damn Emil Loki has a super build I think
it meant to be sleepover build yeah I
was uh I was examining I because you
know I've been going to the gym every
single day hell yeah and uh you're
working on everything yeah everything
full body full body baby he's squatting
oh yeah how much you how much you
putting up baby uh I'm doing volume I'm
not doing um weight but you know I can
easily do
if I if I at my Peak back when back in
the day it was a a meager two plates
but I could deadlift three you're a tall
guy so you know squatting two plates per
size pretty good it's pretty tough it's
my body weight I could squat my body
weight nice but yeah with deadlifts I
could do 3 25 I think something like
that putting it up there but you know
some real quick Hunter definitely used
to power lift I could see that I asked
him how much these are the most he's
ever Squad he he just goes 500.
wow he just went on like 500 or
something a big boy yeah and he's a big
boy I was like why the [__] don't you
want to get back there and he's like
it's boring
I was like it is I hate you it is boring
it is boring uh my proudest achievement
is how much I can hang between my legs
when I do pull-ups now yeah it's I'm 45
pounds but that's not that's for that's
for multiple reps but I but I was I I
was looking at my body in the mirror and
I was like why don't I look more strong
you don't take steroids well but then I
I flex and it's like where the where are
these muscles hiding how come they're
not just ever present it's [__] up
it's annoying you're not no ectomorph
bruh Jesus Christ just accept it you got
the worm build
oh
touch grass hey worms can be jacked too
we all know what touch grass let it rip
we know touch grass it's when you tell a
dork to go outside yeah
touch grass man